robin from atlanta georgia robin how in
the world are you
hey john thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling robin
yeah i'm excited about your new show hey
thank you so much thanks for being on it
yeah sure um i have a stepson now i just
got married
two weeks ago but i i was dating his
father for
three years and he had two weeks prior
to us getting married
he was admitted to a treatment center
for 30 days
for opioid addiction
and the re rehab center has not
contacted you know my husband about
what to do when he gets out this sunday
and you know setting guidelines
he has a history of drug abuse
he has actually stolen
pills from me after i had surgery major
surgery and then
my husband had major surgery he i
actually caught him
stealing them um and we confronted him
he denied it and then he came back and
you know
did say yes i did take him i've had
this addiction since he had had like
hand surgery
when he was like 16. sure so so
you've got a um a i guess a new
son-in-law for lack of better terms
who's an adult yeah i'm assuming
yeah a stepson who is you know he just
turned 21 he still lives with his mother
okay um and so what's your question for
me how can i help
my question is how do we draw boundaries
because
you know i would have thought that the
rehab center would have contacted the
parents and say okay this is what he
needs to do when he gets
out no not for an adult kid no way
really
no not for an adult kid um okay that's
not gonna happen he's a grown man
he's a grown man and as far as as far as
the courts are concerned as far as as
far as his
therapists are concerned as rehab folks
they would never call a brand new
stepmom ever
and so not me normally your father or
his mother yeah
i know it's not my my deal at all but
you know i care for him and i just want
you know i keep telling my husband hey
y'all need to come up with some
boundaries like requirements if he's
you know he's on his dad's insurance
plan he's on his dad's car insurance
which he is pulling him off of that
because he
was probably driving while you know
under the influence of drugs
um and that could affect you know my
husband you know and his
liability as far as you know it being in
his name but as far as boundaries like
hey you need to
you know go to out patient you know
counseling
you need to have drug tests every week
or you know however
and i just need to know how to you know
help my husband decide
what kind of boundaries to set or did we
just act like
it's normal that he's been in treatment
for 30 days
no i in fact you nailed it you
when he gets out you have a welcome home
like a
a welcome out celebration
you take him out to breakfast or to
lunch and you tell him that he's loved
and you're excited that he's back and
then you tell him
um that you're rooting for him and
you're cheering for him
and then you set a date for a couple of
days later two days three days later
and you say we're gonna have a
boundaries conversation
because you're out and we want to be a a
part of
your life moving forward and a part of
being in you being a part of our life
moving forward is
you're gonna have to get your own car
insurance you're gonna have to have your
own place to live
you're gonna have to um pay your way
if you steal from us we're gonna call
the police
it's just it's just like you laid it out
what it sounds like is
your husband's nervous about making that
those boundaries
about drawing those lines about really
wrapping things up
and um that can be from
guilt that can be from um
goodness who knows man it can be from um
frustration it can be from annoyance at
his first wife who knows where those the
the the the
challenges of drawing boundaries at end
of the day
you just what you just said take them
out and draw the boundaries
that means that you and your husband
your new husband are gonna have to
also go have your own conversation about
what those boundaries are going to be
what are they going to look like what
are they going to
sound like what are we going to hold
them to it and
are we going to hold him accountable if
he violates those boundaries
what happens when you come home and he's
in your in your living room
after you told him he's got to call you
what happens when
he quote unquote borrows some money
or what happens when he comes home and
he is all
in on getting well totally invested
kicking butt
working hard are you going to be able to
forgive him
are you going to be able to love him are
you going to be able to let him go to
his mom's house where you don't like the
way things are handled over there
and come back to your house you and your
husband are gonna have to deal with your
hearts on this deal
and really come up with some clear
boundaries for you guys
before you start putting boundaries on
somebody else